foreign
well John the um the crypto um
gossip meal Mill continues oh thank
goodness man apparently now um there's
not much really Tony has gathered up
clients who are seeking five billion
dollars in Damages from FTX celebrity
endorsers
in other words a celebrity went on and
told you to buy crypto from FTX which
went bankrupt went belly up because uh
the guy was running a Ponzi scheme
basically like we didn't know that about
crypto but anyway Tom Brady his ex-wife
Giselle actor Larry David Shark Tank
star Kevin O'Leary and NBA legend
Shaquille O'Neal five billion dollars
well I guess uh Matt Damon's
um thing of fortune favors the board
that was a different company yeah that
one didn't get he's not yeah I don't
understand the suit I'd probably have to
learn more about what Moskowitz is
trying to do I didn't know you could sue
and endorser you can sue anybody for
anything in hopes you can hassle them
into giving you money even if you're
going to lose the lawsuit right because
these companies don't these people don't
want to spend five years in court with
this ambulance Trace chasing and
go through all their and go through all
their everything that they've ever every
underwear drawer they've ever unpacked
in their socks they don't want to go
through all of that even though the guy
and got a chance of winning because
endorsing something when you're a
celebrity that you know nothing about
has been done since time began they're
not liable for
the FTX crash so but hey that's absolute
hogwash I mean I I'm not a fan of FTX
I'm not a fan of crypto certainly not a
fan of bankman fried or fried whichever
way you want to say it and uh pride is
my preference and yeah but the uh in so
many ways yeah uh but you know the whole
thing is a scam but come on dude here's
what's important Tom Brady might be
stupid for endorsing it but he's not
liable he's not a criminal yeah that's
just dumb
I think the the important part of the
story The most important thing that all
of us need to put into our pocket and
not forget
is that when it came down to it only one
celebrity
said no I
and it's James favorite celebrity of all
time Taylor Swift Taylor Swift asked FDX
about its legality of what they were
selling they offered her 100 million
dollars she walked away from it and she
walked away yeah she thought it was a
scam
you gotta love it I can just see her
like writing a song in her bedroom like
she's writing her diary and then she
picks up the phone and she just says hey
can you tell me that these are not
unregistered Securities and the FTX guys
were like we'll call you back and then
she went back to singing herself
according to the attorney who's doing
the lawsuit
so I'm not saying Taylor didn't I didn't
didn't turn down the endorsement because
it was scummy I cannot hear her saying
can you tell me these are not
unregistered securities
I'm calling absolute Bull on that
that is not a phrase that would come out
of Taylor Swift's mouth okay I don't
think you're a true Swifty Dave
I'm not a hater I like Taylor I mean I
I'm not it's not a music thing but I
mean I don't she's a Nashville
originally came up here we all watched
her grow her careers I'm not a hater but
I mean you know can you tell me this is
an illegal maybe would she say that
maybe unless somebody put this phrase in
her mouth and said you need to ask them
this sure but this guys this guy's full
of it
she did not say that she did turn them
down though to her credit yeah we'll
give her big time stars for that 100
million bucks sponsorship for the tour
uh well before negotiations broke down
last spring sources told the financial
times with the FTX then billionaire CEO
bankman fried uh intimately involved in
the talk so he's sitting with time he's
trying to get it he's trying to get
Taylor to sign up here for a hundred
million dollars of course he was going
to pay her in crypto that's probably why
I'm kidding maybe not but anyway yeah ah
hey kudos to Taylor James I think you
should be proud of your favorite singer
songwriter yeah like she did good when
the chips were down she did good yeah
well I um
hey honestly because
the the other guys I kind of I can't
even accuse them of being sellouts no
like I don't I don't know that they just
gave a you know that they just took
money I think they actually believed in
the crypto stupid stuff and actually
thought it was a good idea to invest in
the crypto stupid stuff and so they said
yeah
I mean like I don't think Shaq is a is a
shill for any you can buy him for any
amount of money to sell anything I
really don't believe that about no and
and you and I both people come pitch us
and say hey you wanna you wanna
advertise this product and I had a
meeting today with somebody walking me
through here's what this looks like and
here's what we're about and here's what
we do and we just say no yeah if we
don't like it or if we like it but if I
say yes if I wouldn't sell it if I
wouldn't try to talk my own relative my
best friend into doing it then I'm not
going to tell you guys to do it that's
right that's our rule at Ramsay we don't
endure stuff but these guys honestly
they they probably bought something they
probably told their friends get in on
this yeah yeah that's all right yeah
it's a strange lawsuit but it's a it's a
bogus lawsuit once again Taylor Swift
I'm just saying top of the heat
Moskowitz Adam Moskowitz
and he's out in the news
he's doing interviews
he's that kind of attorney
the kind of attorney instead of having a
case he tries to try it in the court of
public opinion yeah yeah this is what's
known as a glorified ambulance Chaser
right here yeah so companies basically
if y'all don't know most companies just
cave
you sue them they just go oh God I don't
want to be tied up in court and people
do too and you know who didn't do that
the other day Paltrow
she took the fake ski accident guy
all the way to ground baby you know what
he got embarrassed that's what he got
embarrassed and now now they're going
after him for her attorney's fees of
course I hope they get them absolutely
yeah because you know because he thought
he could just bully a celebrity and then
instead of going through the hassle that
the that you bully the celebrity they'll
give you money even though you know
you're wrong and hit that guy you know
he he knows I didn't know much about it
I was just surprised that she showed up
at the in court this is what when when
people out there uh in the think tank
things and all that say we need tort
reform that's what they mean it's these
bogus butt attorneys suing people that
are in the spotlight and knowing that
even though the lawsuit holds absolutely
no water at all zero basis to win they
think they can just do it enough that uh
that you're just gonna write a check and
occasionally run into one that won't and
that uh Paltrow took them all the way to
ground good for her good for her so
that's how it's done so yeah that's I'm
sorry I
we endure stuff for a living we are not
if the company that we endorse
unbeknownst to us does something wrong
we are not financially or legally liable
we believe in it we don't endorse it we
check it out we don't endorse it if we
don't we we do our best we're not good
we're not we're not shills and I don't
think these guys are shills and I think
this guy just he thinks he's going to
hassle these celebs into giving him
money five billion dollars I'm a big dog
tourney no you're not you're a freaking
ambulance Chaser I'll just say Taylor
Swift was right again yeah there it is
who knew who knew there it is James knew